im russischen Staatsfernsehen zeigen sie
heute lange Schlangen vor den
Wahllokalen die Botschaft seht her sie
alle wollen zu Russland gehören
für alles Gute stimmen wir ab wir hoffen
darauf dass es geschehen wird dass alles
Gute was es in Russland gibt zu uns
kommt
doch vor die Kamera geht hier in der
selbsternannten Volksrepublik John jetzt
Knur wer im russischen Sinne spricht
kritische Stimmen kann und will sich
Putins Regime diesen Tagen noch weniger
leisten als sonst tausende fliehen vor
der Teilmobilmachung aus Russland über
die Grenzen wie hier nach Georgien
ich weiß nicht wann ich zurückkommen
kann vielleicht nie ich habe mein
Zuhause verloren
weil sich hier seit Tagen kilometerlange
Schlangen bilden hat Georgien die Grenze
gestern für Fußgänger geöffnet
auch in der Ostukraine fürchten manche
die Mobilisierung ihrer Männer die
besetzten Gebiete sollen nach den
scheinreferenten annektiert werden dann
gehören sie aus russischer Sicht zum
Staatsgebiet im lange umkämpften
Mariupol gingen Wahlhelfer am Vortag
noch einmal von Tür zu Tür begleitet von
Soldaten es wählt wer nicht geflohen ist
manche zumindest unter vorsichtigem
Protest das ist illegal wir wollen nicht
dass jeder sieht was wir hier tun
ob sie den Anschluss an Russland wollen
diese Frau macht ihr Kreuzbein nein das
ist einen Unterschied macht daran glaubt
sie nicht
wir entscheiden nicht die über uns
entscheiden
dieser Mann geht deshalb gar nicht erst
zur Abstimmung
ich bin dafür dass Mariupol in der
Ukraine bleibt historisch gesehen ist
das so
russland will die Geschichte umschreiben
auch Mario Poll soll russisch werden
nach Lesart des Kreml die Annexion der
besetzten Gebiete könnte schon Ende der
Woche kommen
ja heute gehen die scheinreferenten zu
Ende und Christian Semm ist unser
Korrespondentin Moskau wie geht es jetzt
weiter in dem Zeitablauf
ja es könnte jetzt ganz schnell gehen
also bis zum Nachmittag wird in den
betroffenen Gebieten ja noch abgestimmt
und dann könnte es am Abend schon erste
Ergebnisse geben die dann veröffentlicht
werden wobei die natürlich sehr wenig
bis gar keine Aussagekraft haben wir
haben von den Bedingungen noch mal
gehört unter denen diese Befragung da
entstanden sind aber es könnte dann
morgen schon der Erfolg dieser
Referenten hier verkündet werden und
dann geht es schnell weiter dann wird
das Ganze in Gesetzesform gegossen geht
dann durch die Duma und dann wird
erwartet bestätigt ist das noch nicht
dass Vladimir Putin am Freitag eine Rede
halten könnte und dort dann den
Anschluss wie das hier genannt wird der
entsprechenden Gebiete verkündet wird
das macht auch Sinn aus russischer Sicht
dass das jetzt schnell geht denn Putin
braucht er einen Erfolg und will auch
sein Volk mitnehmen bei dieser
Militäroperation vor allem auch weil die
Teil Mobilisierung ja so hoch umstritten
ist und wir gerade diesen Exodus sehen
von den werfähigen Männern die jetzt
schadenweise Ausland verlassen
Einschätzung von unserem Korrespondenten
in Moskau Christiansen vielen Dank